uh the next speaker um i actually found
uh she is uh teaching a winter course at
princeton i got the email saying oh
there's a class on the teddy bear so i'm
like hey hey what's your research in so
because some cool stuff that where she
works and invited her to come speak at
this conference and very short notice
and she said yes we're all thankful for
her turning around such a quick switch a
quick turnaround
and
english
is technically her third language
in order of learning
everyone please welcome to the stage
boreana hello everyone my name is
boreana and i work at the office of
population research at princeton
university
i've been using r for over 15 years now
and it's been incredible to see how the
language has evolved
all right let me tell you a little bit
about dna or genetics data
dna looks like a twisted ladder with uh
steps that the ends of which are these
four nitrogen
bases that um
have
lat names i can't really pronounce
properly but if you
uncoil um
and call it you can imagine two lines
running simultaneously or in parallel
and with the number with the letters a t
c
or g
with the
requirement that
a and t
player and c and g or in other words if
at a particular spot on in one line you
have an a
then on the corresponding spot on the
other line you can have only t or a
and the same with the c and g and
people refer to a spot on the genome as
a locus or a snip and refer to these
bases as alleles
and if the two
lines or sometimes the reported ms
strands are a number
the alleles could be numbered
but the
more
interesting or
distinction between alleles that is made
is
one of them is called the major allele
and the other one the minor and
that depends on which one
is more prevalent in the population so
at this particular
spot or locus that i have sectioned
if more people um
in in the population have an a on either
spot
on either line then a would be
called the major allele and t would be
called the minor allele
and so genetics data
sometimes could come in the form of two
lines per person with these
letters a t c
or g
but more often the way it comes is
in one line and at a particular spot or
locus
there will be a number of how many
copies a person has of the minor allele
so
um
if
there are
tnt
on both lines there will be two copies
of and and t is the minor allele will be
two copies and in this case it'll be a
one one copy or
in the case of where a and a will be
zero copies and then there'll be another
file called a map file
that has all these
spots or locus
enumerated and then
the second column that tells which is
the minor allele at optical response
um
so
so i was given a program
that would generate this type of
genetics
data
and a trade and it would take about like
20 parameters
and then it would produce
four different files one at the family
level and
three at the siblings level
and the
the the basic
idea was that some of these parameters
didn't vary from simulation to
simulation like
the total number of families how many
children each family would have the
number of snips or
loci and
there are these other parameters that
i was supposed to give to the model it
was a very complicated model
the program was written by a biologist
who
took into account
all kinds of theories
that i don't know anything about
but i was given a list of parameters um
then i just decided that
i should make 10 simulations
and of course with all these
random numbers being generated i need to
keep track of random seats so i could
reproduce things so we had total of 50
000
of families and 1200 snips that's like
the gist of this slide
but then there's this other
parameters that um they're like broken
into sets of two
i'm not gonna
go into too much detail about them but
they
had
values that had to vary
and
one of them had
had to do with heritability which
people define as the
proportion of variation
of the trade that is explained by genes
so there were two of those parameters
and they had to
you would try low medium and high values
for them
and then there's like
two parameters for correlation
between siblings
of
some part of the environment and then
there were two
parameters for these um
like dominance part of the model
and
early on um it was decided that
one of them would just keep at zero and
not vary
but
you can calculate quickly there's like
72 combinations so it's not a huge
number
but
something that
i had to
work with
okay the analysis that i had to run
had a very similar flow to the
simulations so
i get the simulated files prep them
make like an input file
to the analysis program and then i would
get some results
and so the goal is to simulate 10 cents
for each parameter combination and um to
begin with i said okay let me take one
of them and just run it
on a linux server
and it took eight hours
to simulate the data and for just about
10 gigabytes of data which is not a huge
amount but you know it adds up
and i'm like okay well let's then um run
the analysis program uh some
one of which i wrote and that
one took about two hours to run
so i thought okay
i need to do something
here
but before i tell you what i decided to
do which you already know what it was
let me kind of tell you what kind of
analysis people run on these types of
data
so the
the very first um
and it's still being run type analysis
that people run is to discover snips
that means to discover snips that are
associated with the given trait and to
do that they run thing as something
called genome-wide association studies
which basically is like a
regression or association models that
would
use all
available
genetics data and see
if any
snip or locus
has a
significant association with the outcome
and um usually the results are come
plotted in something called the
manhattan plot
and people use a very very stringent
p-value
because there's like multiple um
comparisons being made because human
genome has like
2 million or i don't know in the
millions of
of these snips
um they're showing on the first slide
and so you can see the very few of them
actually make it through the
cutoff
for the p values and that's why they
call this the manhattan plot
so
this is actually used very successfully
to find
diseases for example that are caused
primarily by one gene
something that they call mendelian
disease
but
people um
after running many many of these and of
course you need
with so many
snips or like variables columns if you
will you need a good number of
people or rows not to be able to get
anywhere
so um
so yes they um
people
came to realize that actually a lot of
traits a lot of disease and a lot of
traits if you're interested in like
social traits
or even height
biometric traits um
actually
many
snips are associated or what they call
it they're
polygenic
they're kind of
defined and not defined but they're
caused by many of the snips
so nowadays
people sometimes would
do other types of analysis but
um for me
i just had to
run this to see if it would pick up the
snips that we
by design
simulated to be associated with the
trade
then another um
common type of analysis that there are
lots of papers written about it is
estimating heritability
which
as i said it's the
proportion of the variation in the trait
that is explained by the
genes so people usually employ something
called
grammar which is basically genome
restricted maximum likelihood
from like
mixed models
and
so some of these parameters that
we gave to the
simulation program
we were specifying heritability and we
were trying to see if we can
recover
because
we kind of knew what it should be
so to sum things up um
it is the same program for all the
simulations and the last year's programs
was the same and each simulation was
independent of each other so
it was like a classic case for uh trying
to do things in parallel
and um
i realized that a lot of people probably
at this conference use big data and are
very used to parallel processing so i
apologize this is
nothing new um
is my one sentence about parallel
processing um which is basically
executing repeated tests simultaneously
on different cores or on different nodes
on a cluster
so as i mentioned i started by running
things on our
linux server which um
soon after i realized had some
limitations
so
then i had to move
the simulations to
high power computing settings which
this is my very
basic picture of it
which stacks
um a lot of cores
or processing power
in one place
but um
we're on a lot of computers nowadays
they come with multiple cores
i like this picture because uh it shows
you the course that they're kind of
separate from each other and they don't
really talk to each other
with the high power computing people
program
ways that they could talk to each other
so
you could even run
not quite independent tasks
on them
um so how i did this in r was um
i used the for each package in the two
parallel package um and the forage
package
um if you're not familiar with it
it runs pretty much like a for loop in
our if you use it with the do operator
except
your
output would probably get produced it
will get back to you as a list
but um
the 4-h loop has the capability to use
the dual power operator which
allows each like iteration of the loop
to
use a different core
but you have to tell it how many
clusters or how many cores or workers
you want to use and then you have to
register them so
from then on my job is very easy i would
just put all my parameters
into separate vectors and then
call them right before i call my main
simulation program
and
then
if you use a do parallel package it's a
good idea to stop your cluster sound
so that your memory gets cleared
so
that's what i wanted to share with you
today
and
thank you for listening